welcome back many of America's prisons
are not just overcrowded they're also
understaffed and a deadly incident at a
Delaware Correctional Facility last year
is putting a focus on that problem
Jericka Duncan has been investigating
the case on February 1st 2017 inmates at
Vaughn Correctional Center a
maximum-security prison in Delaware took
six correctional officers and a
counselor hostage I just imagined a
bloodbath elisa Profaci a correctional
officer for nearly 30 years was assigned
to help rescue her colleagues when I got
inside the major was out there and I
said what's going on he said it's not
good they've taken charlie building they
have hostages and there's blood
everywhere six hostages were released
during the 18 hour standoff but 47 year
old lieutenant Stephen Floyd a 16 year
veteran did not make it out alive the
day after the incident I did not go back
Profaci is among more than 200
correctional officers and medical staff
at Vaughn who have resigned or retired
since the uprising according to the
Department of Justice nationwide there
is an average of one guard for every
five inmates on the day of the uprising
Profaci says Charlie building were Floyd
was attacked had just four guards for
127 inmates most prisons in this country
are not adequately staffed Lauren Brooke
Ison is with the Brennan Center for
Justice she says understaffing is a
problem in at least 16 other states and
the need she says is often meant through
overtime most correctional guards are
required to work and ments overtime
we're talking 14 16 18 hour shifts
according to the correctional officers
Association of Delaware during any shift
about 40% of staff is working overtime
ELISA Profaci says it's only a matter of
time before another deadly takeover
happens at another prison my prayers are
with them and I fight to fight for them
until we get what we need to be
and where's that that are safer
conditions for CBS this morning Saturday
Jericka Duncan Wilmington Delaware